my name is henrik platz i'm a computer
scientist living in berlin and this is
blockchain 102.
i have been doing things with
cryptography for about 15 years now
i'm not a cryptographer per se but
mostly interested in communications
protocols i've been doing a lot of
access control of id related research
um
as of late i have my own company we're
doing payment stuff
fair warning i did have some bitcoin in
the early 2010s
i sold the last of it around 2016 i
think
and since then i've been more and more
concerned with the
basically the blockchain hype
and how it captures resources and
resources does not only refer to
electrical power but also engineering
capacity
public attention and and
mind space basically
this talk is not going to be bitcoin 101
i assume a basic knowledge of the
bitcoin and ethereum networks at least
what they are and how they are used i'm
not going to introduce
the basic concept of blockchains
what i
will do is spotlight several interesting
uh projects and protocols in in relation
to that
i am going to play fast and luth with
the definitions i'm
not going to stick to a very specific
definition
of what a blockchain is versus a hash
chain
anything basically related or in the
vicinity of the distributed ledger
technologies is fair game
i hope by the end of this talk you will
have noticed that i'm not a big fan of
anything i'm about to show you
and i do reserve the right to poke fun
at any and all bad ideas
as a baseline
i think bitcoin is a work of genius
it is
very elegant in its simplicity
the original paper by satoshi nakamoto
in 2008
um showing the first combination proof
of work distributed ledger technology
distributed ledger and hash chain
solved the byzantine agreement problem
on a permissionless
in a permissionless environment that is
civil proof
and only be based on reasonable
cryptographic assumptions
like i said it is elegant in its
simplicity
it solves the problem for a very
specific niche
and
there are at least three or four design
decisions that are very integral and and
irreducible in the bitcoin system
taking any of them out
will
harm or break the entire system in
obvious and or non-obvious ways
which of course is why people are going
to do that
um bitcoin itself has only very limited
scripting
in its transaction
scheme
it's not designed to be a programming
language it's not designed for smart
contracts but the scripts are merely a
very nice serialization format for
authorization decisions
um so that you don't have to
don't have to hard code into the network
all the possible authorization
schemes that are
that should exist should be able to
exist
but any user of the network can
[Music]
build an
a script that um authorizes the spending
of funds
in any way they like
bitcoin is
a very elegant scheme and it's mostly
useless
that's the point that's my that's what
i'm sticking with it
sticking with
since
the
only
purpose it can have is a global
decentralized globally available
currency
but it does have very very low
transaction throughput
and
very high energy usage at that
ethereum came later
it tried to improve
by having a full-blown true and complete
smart contract language
basically ethereum is a global computer
that as a side effect
also processes payment transactions
first we're going to look at so bitcoin
bitcoin ethereum both proof of work
we're going to look at the different
proof of something schemes
the easiest one
of course is proof of authority
works mostly like you would imagine it's
going to work you have the normal
transactions you have notes there's
verified that transactions are correct
they put them into a block and sign the
entire block
with their own
private key and a sufficient form of
authoritative nodes needs to sign a
transaction block for it to become valid
very simple very efficient
and requires trust in those authorities
how they are chosen is completely out of
scope and
non-obvious
it is the one of the standard
constructions for private or
permissioned blockchains
so those
that's why we say those are basically
just glorified databases
a slight step up is proof of stake
proof of stake though is
basically the same as proof of the
authority except that authority is now
indirectly established by some sort of
stake
such as token holdings
if you hold enough token of the
underlying
currency
you have more stake and therefore more
authority
these systems may sometimes offer an
integrated punishment mechanism
called slashing so that if you
field your authority
in an inappropriate way if you lie
you're you're penalized
currently proof of stake is the holy
grail for
the established proof of work systems to
get rid of this energy waste stigma
for example both ethereum and yota i'm
going to talk about yota later on
currently are planning to pivot to a
proof of stake based system
any day now
free from steak has a very
hard problem
how do you initially distribute the
stake
it's
that's why i said it's it's essentially
the same as with authority you need to
somehow select the authorities you trust
you need to select stakeholders you
trust
and they then get to determine what
happens on the network
a very popular mechanism to do that is
sale of tokens
which is why i have this little red flag
next to it a sale of tokens or initial
coin offering
um
i'm going to invent a network the very
cool cool chain
i'm going to sell 600 billion dollars
worth of cool chain tokens
and then you all are on my network and
i'm 600 million dollars richer
i don't care what happens to the network
afterwards
an alternative to this is to bootstrap
the proof-of-stake system off of an
existing blockchain
for example the ethereum chain or iota
is going to do that i think today which
is
yeah it doesn't have the same problem
oh no
it doesn't have the same benefit for the
creators of the network
uh still
the
problem with the general problem with
proof of stake is that there is no
built-in defense against centralization
bitcoin solves this centralization
problem by sheer physics
it's very very hard to
have more than 51 percent of the global
computing power currently
but in a proof of stake system there is
no built-in defense against anyone
accumulating 51 percent of stake on
their account or on any suck puppet
accounts
this is what i mean when i say there's
no civil resistance because on the
internet nobody knows if you're a dog
and nobody knows
who and how many you are or claim to be
uh
deeply ingrained problem is that even if
you bootstrap this thing correctly
you have no defense against it becoming
centralized later on by a stake being
transferred and accumulated onto one big
stakeholder
the other pos
is proof of storage i'm not going to
talk about that very much there's uh one
very uh
well there's one
scheme that has
gained notoriety because basically the
introduction of the chia network
uh crashed the global ssd market it was
very
very hard to buy any disks at that time
also
the operations on this network destroy
ssds in less than a year
so it's also it's really expensive to to
operate even though it doesn't use
electricity it uses ssds
and basically there's no
other use so i'm not going to talk about
later
the funniest proof system
and actually
the thing i came across that motive
motivated me
to
give this talk is proof of elapsed time
also called poet
the idea is very simple and genius
instead of computing hashes for proof of
work and proof of work in this case
means waiting sometime instead of
computing hashes
you just do nothing you go to sleep
compared to a proof of work system this
offers incredible energy savings
and it's a drop-in solution it behaves
exactly like a proof-of-work system in
any
any network you can just swap out the
proof-of-work system for your proof of
elapsed time system
mostly it makes sense in permissioned
environments private blockchains
i do have a small
there is a very small question a teeny
tiny teeny tiny issue
which guarantees do other notes have
that
no one cheats no one is going to wake up
earlier than assigned
well of course intellect gx
the uh for those who who don't know that
sgx is the secure enclave in intel
processors intel guarantees that um
inside this processor secure computation
can take place
and
programs that run inside the enclave
can prove that they are running in an
officially
officially official intel secure enclave
and are not being controlled by any
anybody else from the outside
and does allow trusted execution
small problem
obviously um this isn't going to
this wasn't going to
be secure forever
there was a very nice
break of intel sgx
a year two years ago
it went so far that they offer an
attestation as a service
service there's a twitter account and if
you need anything signed by a real intel
sjx enclave anything at all any
attestation to any any fact
you can just tweet it to this twitter
account and
they will happily sign it for you
and this is one of the
underlying
topics i want to draw your attention to
is that
some of these systems appear to be
secure but they're just shifting the
security barrier
somewhere else
and hope you don't look
and and hope you don't look too closely
yet
at how and where the security is now
for example mobile coin is the other
extreme basically
mobile coin has a proof
i would call it proof of complexity
mobile coin is a mobile device focused
new cryptocurrencies started last year
and it pulls every cryptographic
register theirs
they're using stellar consensus network
they have net zero knowledge proofs for
everything wrist strategy abstractions
snore anonymous signatures peterson
commitments you name it they have it
i'm
[Music]
there's a very good book about
about it
this mechanics of mobile coin
i've linked here
so even though i'm showing you this part
of the abstract to scare you i'm very
grateful that exists because not
everyone
has um
an abstract that
so clearly states what they are doing
and and what they are hoping to achieve
many of the documentation
a lot of the documentation that i've
been reading for this talk
um
doesn't clearly tell you what they are
doing and why
two small problems with uh mobile coin
the entire token supply is pre-mined
which is one of the other red flags
85 percent of the current mobile coin
uh in existence and all the mobile coins
that will ever be in existence are held
by the creators of mobilecoin
they can sell it to you at will
and their security against double
spending so they have security and they
have privacy guarantees that
probably maybe are good
it's um
[Music]
like i said it's very complex and
i wouldn't bet on there not being any
implementation errors
but apps absent any implementation
mistakes
their
privacy guarantees and properties are
probably good
but their security against double
spending is entirely reliant on sjx
enclaves
see previous slide
circling back to bitcoin and
misusing bitcoin i introduce it as not
having an entire full-blown scripting
language but you can still do cool stuff
with it nevertheless
one of the earliest examples of that i
saw was due to dan kaminski who sadly
passed away this year
in 2011 in his black ops of tcp talk
um he
uh presented a tribute to len sesserman
who died that year
on the bitcoin main net that is embedded
in the bitcoin blockchain
and
thus verifications of the entire
blockchain is dependent on this tribute
being present
which is a very nice idea i'm not sure
but i think it was one of the first
examples of this
a lot of people have embedded stuff into
the blockchain later on
and a very
moving memorial to a friend
another very cool hack uh that is
actually
not being used as a hack anymore but
it's in production is the lightning
network
um
starting in 2016. i'm going to
explain this in a little bit more detail
but
not entirely in detail
since we have other
content to get to
um what's interesting about the lighting
network is that it works with bitcoin
more or less without changes there were
very small changes made to the bitcoin
mainnet
but no fundamental changes there's no
new scripting language only
new instructions in the existing
language
it's a clever use of time locks and
multi signatures
one of the features that most people
aren't aware of is that not only can the
bitcoin scripting language
allow you to put signature restrictions
like procession of a private key
on spending of bitcoins but you can also
put a time lock on it
and can say that a specific amount of
bitcoin can only be spent after some
time basically time either in
unique seconds or in i mean block block
height
since the bitcoin network as a whole has
a more or less predictable
block time of 10 minutes
you can
rather reliably say that some
some amount of money cannot be spent for
48 hours for example
and that's the basic idea here
two parties collaborate to open a
so-called lightning channel payment
channel
they
need to fund this channel on the main
chain
um
like i'm putting the main chain here
and the lightning channel or the
anti-lighting network at this point so
um
[Music]
a properly functioning lightning channel
only is visible in two transactions in
the main network
there's the funding transaction the one
up here
that basically locks up some money
in escrow
essentially in escrow for the channel
and after that
the two parties
exchange transactions amongst themselves
the main network does not need to know
about these transactions
and they can send money back and forth
in this example both start with for
example two bitcoins
both commit two bitcoins for this
channel so the channel has an entire
capacity of four bitcoins
each party starts off with two bitcoins
at first and then they can transfer
or
exchange transactions
that transfer their
any arbitrary partial amount of that
in either direction
so i'm starting with um 2. 0.2 bitcoins
to b now the internal state is that b
has a bit more money
then i'm transferring in this example
1.5 in the other direction now b has
less money and so on and so on and so on
these
actions these transactions
are very fast since they are just
signature two signatures and the tcp
connection
and therefore can happen instantaneously
at the end of
their channel both parties can mutually
agree to close the channel
and only the last state
is written back onto the blocked the
main blockchain
the cool thing about this is that
due to the clever use of time locks and
multi-six
all the amount of money in the channel
is protected against
a cheating party
these in intermediate blocks need to be
signed by both parties
so the end transaction is signed by both
parties
but there is a
democrat sort basically
um
hanging over this using the time locks
if any party cheats the other party
automatically gains the authority to
claim the entire funds for themselves
this prevents
the parties from cheating because who
wants to lose two bitcoins
but also means that
the maximum outstanding amount of money
on this channel
is limited to the escrow amount
this
in the channel for example in this
example at no point can any party owe
the the other more than four bitcoins
if you
want to buy something really expensive
bitcoins a bit much but if you want to
buy something really expensive um you
cannot use this channel you need to
close it and open another one and that's
the other big problem
the money that is held in escrow for
this channel cannot be used for anything
else if you open a lighting channel to
someone that money is gone for the
moment
and even worse through the time lock
mechanism if the other party misbehaves
you cannot access the money for some
time 48 hours for example
so it is a very cool hack
but i don't think it has any particular
usefulness
especially since
due to this
[Music]
because the outstanding amount cannot x
the outstanding
money
amount cannot
exceed the entire capacity capacity of
the channel
it
does not
lend itself to being used for example
for payments
it's okay if you have a friend and you
lend them like a bit of money today and
they pay you back tomorrow
the after that you don't have any money
with you and they lend you something and
you pay them back
but for a channel to exist over a long
time
its
mean amount needs to be zero
it
must be the same on both sides
um while most transactions in most
systems are in a merchant and customer
relationship
if i buy something
i pay money to the merchant
very seldomly do they pay me money
um this is the fundamental problem of
the lightning network
they do have an extension
i've been um
drawing this with two participants
lightning channels can be chained so if
a and b have a channel and b and c have
a channel
there can be a value transaction between
a and c mediated through b
but the problem that the
outstanding amount on the channel cannot
exist exceed the funding amount doesn't
go away
back to something that was actually
designed to be programmable
ethereum
very shortly after the introduction of
ethereum um there was the dao
at that point that was a singular noun
um the decentralized autonomous
organization today dao is mostly used as
a
collective noun basically a dao but at
that point it was the tao
was a cool idea
it's um
from the code of law code is law people
basically you have a venture capital
fund um that anybody can contribute
money to ether to
and anyone who has contributed money
into the fund
has voting rights and
basically governance rights on on the
amount and can can
vote on where this money should be
invested
proportional to the amount of money they
invested
it had its own token at that point
and was crowdfunded
end of june 2016
and sold
at that time more than uh for more than
150 million dollars
this didn't last long
there was a vulnerability in there so
the dao has a function to
split out subdials
if there's no consensus about what's
supposed to happen so if the majority of
the
funders decide to do something that a
minority disagrees with
the minority can split out their money
into a child now
that then behaves like a normal dow
and anyone can propose to create such a
child tower
the
code that processed that request had a
bug
a classic time of check time of use bug
the
smart contract first retrieved the ether
um to be sent to the child or from the
main now and only then checked the
balance of the
account that proposed
the split
but at that point a recursive call is
possible
so you can nest
um this problem
which means the transaction
the next transaction happens so it
deducts money from the main
funds it into the child now
recursive call deduct money from main
fund into child deduct money for main
and so on
and
[Music]
the check against the balance would only
happen afterwards
someone found this
and
well
people say abuse used it
and by june 2016 like two weeks later
about 50 million
us dollars worth of
tokens where in the child dial that was
controlled
was supposed to be controlled
about to be controlled by one party
luckily
as luck would have it there was a
built-in uh waiting period for proposals
to go through and people to read their
mails and stuff like that that meant all
the money that was in this child now
couldn't be transferred out for at least
48 days for exactly 48 days
so there was some discussion time
as to what should happen now this was
the big discussion of that time
because one party says
code's law
someone used the code and obviously it's
correct what they did because the code
allowed that
though the main ethereum network did not
quite see it that way
which led to a hard fork
of the entire blockchain
that's why we have ethereum and ethereum
classic now
and i don't think anyone uses ethereum
classic
like i said the dow had its own token
was one of the first there is now a
generic mechanism to create your own
tokens it's the
basically an api specification
if your contract fulfills the smart this
api
then you are an erc20 token
and
these tokens behave like money something
you can transfer
you can query the balance
those are the only relevant functions um
so if you put a contract onto the
ethereum blockchain
that fulfills the specification you have
your own money
lots of people do that
there's
more than 480 000 token contracts
currently on the blockchain on the
ethereum blockchain
and all the details of those tokens up
to the token creator obviously it's a
smart contract it only has an interface
and you can deposit and transfer money
where this money comes from
this amount
value comes from is not specified
entirely up to the token creator
these tokens can have their own value
independent of the ether
and some do
and that's how that works
what you can use this for
is what i call crypto enabled financial
trickery
since these tokens can basically only be
traded you can you have dogecoin and you
i if i would want dogecoin i could buy
it from you and then you would have some
other amount of currency
or some other kind of currency
and now we have over 480 000 different
kinds of currency to choose from
this
[Music]
enables exciting opportunities of
arbitrage
if i find two marketplaces that sell
token pairs at different prices
i can buy one token at the cheaper price
and sell it at the more expensive price
that's the classic thing that you would
also do on a normal stock exchange the
cool thing about ethereum and smart
contracts is that
the smart contracts are executed
automatically and enforce automatically
the contract stipulations
no matter what they look like
one of them really mind-blowing or very
yeah mind-opening things that they can
you can do with that
is an unqualified flash loan
basically it's a smart contract that
always has the following form
i give you some amount of money
you do
whatever you want
and then you return the money
with some fee
plus some fee
um
[Music]
you're completely free what to do
whatever you want in this step
you can
[Music]
like like i said exploit arbitrage i put
opportunities you can sell something at
a different marketplace and then buy
back
the uh important thing is that you pay
me back plus interest
and the cool thing about the ethereum or
the the
smart contract language is that this is
guaranteed to happen atomically
um either
the entire thing happens
or nothing happens at all except for
some gas spending
if you cannot return the amount for
example because your cool
arbitrage
trick didn't work out
it's reverted and never happened
um
so i can enforce for you to pay me some
money and you can
so that's for me good for me good for me
is i can enforce you to pay me some
interest
and good for you you have a lot of money
like i said it's very good for exporting
arbitrage opportunities
and it's also very good for exploiting
smart contract vulnerabilities because a
lot of these need some funding
and if you have a vulnerability that
doubles your input for example
it's very cool if you can land
if you can borrow 100 million dollars
for like 10 000 dollars in an interest
and then double it
and finally decentralized finance
defy
devi devi
decentralized finance davie
um
it's just the umbrella and marketing
term for everything we just talked about
it allows most
operations that you can do with
traditional financial instruments but on
the blockchain
borrowing landing flash borrowing high
frequency trading price speculation
and swapping between token pairs
like swapping dogecoin for
that's one of the other coins
dogecoin for tether or back something
like that
now
this is one of the subjects
i'm most often laughing about
because as you can see on this slide
there's
a huge
a huge amount of money in here
there's a
hell of money
bound in the defeat contracts
but the complexity
[Music]
means that very often
well code is law but the law did does
not always say what you thought it is
uh by my estimation and when i when i
search for that i've i found this
website which very
graciously already has an entire list i
didn't need to compile it
by my estimation about approximately
every other week someone exploits a buck
in one of the davie systems
to the tune of 10 to 100 million us
dollars
these are just from like the last two
months
now for something completely different
the iota network
iota is um
not a blockchain
so like i said i didn't don't want to
dwell on the terms
but they call themselves a tangle
it's a directed as acyclic graph it's
not a chain
but
every
every transaction
is supposed to confirm to other
transactions
it doesn't have any proof of work so
it's very fast and energy efficient
it doesn't use a lot of energy i'm not
sure if it's efficient if it doesn't
do anything but
it doesn't use a lot of energy
it doesn't have any proof of work it
doesn't have any proof of anything
really
it doesn't have any transaction fees you
just are required to trans uh verify to
other transactions
it's designed or marketed for internet
of things
things that works
it's actually run by a foundation uh
with
located here in berlin
and the the
thing that sets it apart from
one of the things that sets it apart
from all of the other
established players is that it's not a
decentralized system
their consensus protocol
is that they have a central coordinator
that has to sign off on every
transaction
if the coordinator didn't verify it it
didn't happen
there are several attacks on the iota
system in the past
and
the foundation
could uh
luckily could stop the attacks by
basically just stopping the coordinator
like i said the coordinator is just one
of the things
that makes this one unique
the other
unique thing about yota is that they
want to be unique they have their own or
they had they had their own
home built cryptography
one of the rules is never really on
cryptography and not only did they build
their own cryptography they did it in
trinary
so in their system there isn't just zero
or one but they have minus one zero or
one
everything is a twit
and of course
their
custom built
trinary hash function was broken
in 2019 the the iota foundation did not
react favorably to this um date
it's um
the second link on this page has some of
the history or
some of the major history basically
there were very interesting twitter
discussions and threats against the
researchers threats of legal action
including
the iota foundation claiming
that or the creators not sure of the
foundation itself the creators claiming
that they knew about the vulnerability
and it was there on purpose
to act as a sort of copy protection
uh their defense is that if anybody
would
copy the iota protocol since everything
is open source
and build a clone iota network they
could then use this vulnerability to
shut down the other network
which is a bit of [ __ ]
[Music]
in the aftermath they removed the broken
hash function
and replaced it
with one that's based on
cacao the
three hash function
but still in trinary and it's still
broken
nobody
cares it's still broken
nobody cares
okay
let's move on in our alphabet soup ssi
it's not server side include this time
ssi is supposed to stand for
self-sovereign identities and wikipedia
defines this as an approach to digital
identity that gives individuals control
of their digital identities
and no one knows what that means
there's no single standard nor
specification or shared understanding of
what this might be
the graphic
i put here is one that's most often used
to explain how this is supposed to work
it's indistinguishable from an standard
pki attribute certificate issuance like
you have an issuer that issues a
certificate
that's stored in a wallet and can then
pre-present it to a verifier
for some reason some some reason that
nobody has been able to
explain to me to my satisfaction
is also stored in the blockchain
what
this diagram lacks and what most of
these systems tend to lack is a very
crucial
additional arrow
it's very good if um
i have the cryptographic proof that
some credential was really issued by a
certain issuer
but i still need
to get
trust
in that issuer from somewhere
i still need to know that they are who
they claim they are
and this is something that's basically
entirely ignored in all of the
self-certain identity
schemes i've seen
and
coming up on
key terms there's this thing called a
decentralized identifier the id
which is supposed to be
the the abstraction there's a ws3c
standard
on that and the registry currently lists
114
mutually incompatible did methods
like i said it behaves like an attribute
certificates
this is called a verifiable
credential and one of the only new
things
or one of the things that established
protocols don't have it's not new
is that they should support selective
disclosure
selective disclosure means if i get a
credential
uh to multiple facts like my name is
henrik my last name is plutz i'm living
in berlin i can then present this
credential but
block out
some of the fields
and just prove for example that i'm
living in berlin
if i want something from a billion
authorities
they might not need to know who i am
just that i can prove that i live in
berlin
it's one of the key features for example
of the u-proof system due to stefan
brandt's in 2000 i think
which
was built into microsoft
[Music]
card space i think and for some reason
completely vanish of the face of the
earth nobody ever
heard of it again but it did solve all
of this in 2000 already
um
nevertheless all these self-serve and
identity people
are very eager to show you their
their use cases and their
show showcases
for example this one
presenting information to an employer
in the future you will have your diploma
or your masters
your master's degree as a verifiable
credential
that you can then attach to your
cv when applying for a new job
and your employer will be able to verify
that and doesn't need to trust
that you didn't change your grades
i said very small insignificant issue
i s whether the employer still somehow
needs to trust the issuer
i can go on the blockchain
and open the very cool university of
coolness and issue master's degrees in
coolness-ness
and give everyone a grades
and i can
prove that i really am the
cool university of coolness
but somehow the verifier the potential
employer
still needs to know
whether i am an officially accredited
university whose master's degree is
worth anything
and at that point you have a very
standard pki structure you have a
central authority like a list of
good universities
and from there on you can delegate the
trust down
and you don't need and don't need any of
the decentralized stuff
and in either case you don't need any of
the blockchain stuff i have never
understood why
no i that's not alright
i made this point on twitter once and
someone actually emailed me i
i'm not sure either id union or lucy um
someone emailed me and said that
they kind of know that they don't need
it
but
the problem they are solving is that
there are so many interested parties in
the space so many companies who want to
promote their own wallet product
that there's no way that they can
decide on a governance structure on on a
pki structure on who or trusts whom and
who delegates trust where
so instead they are putting it all onto
the blockchain
and thereby
completely erasing the trace of
where the trust chain comes from
and hope their respective companies
don't notice
so basically it's money laundering for
pki
is what they're using the blockchain for
a related standard in this space is did
com it's um
from the identity foundation very cool
domain name if i say so
it's a
long standard document it's a really
long standards document
it has everything it has json web
messages json web token
it has a custom asynchronous request
reply messaging scheme with multiple
parallel asynchronous threats of
communication it has a routing layer
transport layer discovery there's
everything in there
except provisions for recipient
verification so i can have my uh
decentralized identify my verifiable
credential i could present my verifiable
credential to someone
selectively so that they only
get to know what i want them to know
except i have no idea who they are
which brings us to this year's news
the id wallet
exactly in the last week before this
year's german parliamentary elections
our esteemed government released an app
or one of the intermediaries released an
app to a big
pr fund far called id wallet or released
the
use cases for that
which was supposed to be a
self-sovereign identity system based on
the idcom
um that could in the future be used for
a lot of other things
we're completely ignoring we're
completely ignoring at this point that
germany already has an eid system that
works
but it's not cool it's not blockchain
it's not here
so this
id wallet app
you can use it to create a
self-sovereign identity called basis id
and the self-sovereign identity is
created by having the bundesliga sign
dataset that they extracted from your
national id card
so the self-sovereign identity is
created by the bundesliga essentially
and you can then use this identity to
query the federal transport motor
transport authority
for a copy of your driver's license
that then is
assigned to this um
that is then assigned to this verifiable
credential
nothing you couldn't
just do with you know a database or
signature but um it is a blockchain
system
and it didn't end well a few days after
public release the entire thing was
stopped the official
reason giving is that there was
too much interest to too much load due
to unanticipated high interest in the
system
what
you will find on twitter if you um
looking into um whitman and flipkart who
were the main
actors in this space
is that the entire thing was run on very
badly maintained infrastructure there
were dns stone transfers there
were open subdomains anything you
a lot of things not good
and the code grass is that
little
showed
the privacy problem mentioned earlier
that even though i can very
present present my verifiable credential
to someone in a secure way i have no
idea who whom i'm presenting it to
and that's inherent in the protocol
there's no way to fix it and no plans to
fix it
so the thing
remains shut down for the time being and
probably for good
hopefully
on the subject of silliness
nft
nft stands for non-fungible token
so for comparison the tokens i talked
about before the erc20 tokens are
fungible every token is the same every
time you can replace every token with
any other in bitcoin even there there is
no stable token every time you spend
bitcoin your existing bitcoin gets
destroyed and a new bitcoin is created
yes 20 tokens don't really need to exist
in any
exact meaning of the phrase
but still it's it's just the value there
there's no
countable token
and
not only no countable there's no unique
token
the other standard the newer one erc721
specifies the api for non-fungible
tokens
what it essentially does is track every
token individually the token gets a
token identifier
token gets a token identifier
and
blockchain records who is the current
the identifier of the current owner of
the talk and what the smart contract
then allows is
transferring the token from owner to
owner
normally doesn't store any other
information other than
who the current owner is
um
but
so
this emulates
basically a collectible
a token can be created on the blockchain
and then sold and resold
but now you might be asking where do
these jpegs come in from
of which i've heard so much
what you can do in the token standard is
associate metadata with the token
actually you can't you can associate an
url with the token
that can point to metadata
and this metadata might then optionally
point to
an asset file
could be video could be a free model
anything or some other metadata like the
name of the token
there's something i'm not going to talk
about that's called the interplanetary
file system it's a decentralized storage
system that actually behaves mostly as
you would like it to
most crucially
if if you point to
an ipfs address it's immutable
but that's not the standard
wasn't the standard for a long time
for a long time all the metadata and the
data was just stored on the server of
whoever minted the token or of the
platform that the token was minted on
and
moxie
made this very cool demonstration where
you can look at the same
the identical
non-fungible token on different
platforms
and it would display differently
because the metadata points to a url
that can behave differently depending on
where you come from
so what are nfts good form basically
scams
one of the problems is that there's no
verification requirement no relationship
to any real world identity anyone can
mint any asset into an nft and sell it
they don't need proof of ownership
and if you believe that i have a very
nice bridge to sell you
the
different platforms where you can create
and sell nfts
mostly are tired of the problem now and
are very much much slower to respond to
complaints now
there are entire
so so they're obvious apparently there
are people out there you just go through
for example deviantart take every image
from there
make an nft out of it and try to sell it
it's like if you go on twitter and say i
need that on a t-shirt there will be a
bot that offers to sell you that t-shirt
even though it probably doesn't have the
copyright on whatever you responded to
a very cool thing someone found on
twitter the other day is that
related to the previous slide
if um
a lot of these platforms actually store
the
data the nft data
just
on google cloud services and google's
takedown processes are still working so
you can remove the nft content without
cooperation from the nft platforms
another problem
it's a very complex the entire thing
this leads to many so even if there are
no
engineering or
security vulnerabilities in there this
leads to a lot of successful social
engineering attacks
with the added benefit that any token
that has been stolen
now rightfully kodu's law belongs to the
no owner there was this very famous case
a few months ago of the board apes
very high profile case
[Music]
someone got scammed out of three apes i
think
value like two million dollars
um
[Music]
they
successfully petitioned the trading
platforms to stop health halt trading on
these tokens
which doesn't boil well for the
decentralized nature of this thing but
that's that
for me it's funny to the people affected
it's not
uh
since you have no verification that an
actual person is on the other side or
who is on the other side
um
there's this phenomenon
called
rockpool
basically you start a new project you
announce
broad apes where yesterday's news we are
now doing evolved apes
they are better they are better in every
way they can be used in games
please buy them here
enter money here
and after you've received all the money
you just clean out the accounts and
vanish
this is what happens
a couple of times now i don't have all
the examples on here
sometimes this happens even in teams
there are a couple of posts of people
actually trying to start a project
and then complaining that the
administrator they
they ask they tasked with keeping
safe keeping of the secret keys
just went and took all their money and
it's gone now
in conclusion
there's really not a lot of uses for any
of this except for ponzi schemes and
tricking people
especially it's all self-referential
you can do financial instruments just
fine everything works great it's
not the
energy
most energy conserving way to do that
but
it can give good return on vest of
course you always need to keep in mind
that if you earn money
someone else lost it
so you can do uh the crypto enabled
financial trickery just fine
the core problem of any and all
blockchain projects is the oracle
problem
all the cryptographic stuff all the
verification zero knowledge proofs what
have you only worked within the system
you cannot interface into the real world
in any meaningful way
um because if you
did
if you wanted to
you would need a node that acts as a
mediator between the blockchain world
and the physical world you need to trust
that node
to for example accurately report sensor
data or to accurately
execute some actions
and if you can trust that note to do
that you can also trust the note to do
that without a blockchain
uh like one of the the funniest projects
i've heard was for trash collection
fairness and trash collection there's a
sensor in every trash bin
and trash collectors like municipal
waste
and every trash collector
gets money for the trash they collected
based on the sensor readings
but the sensor nodes of course
can't be part of any blockchain
no energy no nothing no no connectivity
so they just report all their readings
to a central server
and that central server then records uh
all the data on the blockchain and at
that point the central server could just
disperse the
amount due for trash collecting
there's no need to direct the blockchain
into anything here
put into one sentence cryptocurrencies
have more or less by definition only one
use case and that's ponzi schemes and
other scams
there can be i have said that before
there can be
some benefit to having a
pure timestamping service or the
blockchain combines
timestamping and consensus if you don't
need the consensus because anything you
do is centralized by nature anyway
there can be some upside to using
a mercury or a timestamping chain
without any of the
without any of the blockchain overhead
consensus overhead
so this is the end of this talk
i will be available for your questions
now